or je m'inscrire ses fruits mais tue et
cela bizarre comme un sou neuf c'est un
bizarre c'est le match de combat quoi
ils menacent de combat à la tombe
[ __ ] si c'est ça les boeufs cet été
merci et vive la france
j'aime bien comment tu fais ça me fait
mal moi je resterai offrant jeux
musicaux ici c'est mort je vais pas peur
du chômage et de la crise est bien pire
qu'il se prépare à nous emparer d je
comprends rien qu'est-ce qu'on va pas
arriver la fin la femme quoi il faut
faire une prépa pour entrer dans l'armée
ça dépend du régime que tu eu en fait
moi ce que je veux c'est un des plus
durs donc ils prennent pas n'importe qui
surprise
on dit tu es là tu vas faire le stage
content je suis au lieutenant schipper
bienvenue première dp causticité mon cul
ouais c'est les parents tu manges pas
tant flamby
géant
je pense que je sais pas
au secours
on reste à l'affût
sur nos gardes